-Good evening, I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing
well tonight.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
The White House
announced yesterday
that President Biden
was interviewed over two days
as part of the investigation
into his handling
of classified documents.
It was supposed
to be one day,
but, you know,
when you get that man talking.
"Should we come back tomorrow
and wrap this up?"
According to a new report,
White House staffers believe
that President Biden's
handling of the war in Ukraine
and the Hamas attack
on Israel
could define his legacy.
Said Biden, "Oh, good.
So not the bike thing?"
[ Laughter ]
Former President Trump
held a campaign
rally last night
in New Hampshire
and blamed windmills
for killing whales.
While normally when someone
says something like that,
the next thing you see
is the backup quarterback
warming up
on the sidelines.
But nope, they're
leaving him in the game.
House Republicans held
a closed door meeting yesterday
to discuss the speakership,
and one member called it
"a therapy session,"
though if being locked
in a room
with those people for two hours
feels like therapy,
you need to find
a new therapist.
Robert F. Kennedy Jr.
announced yesterday
that he is dropping out
of the Democratic primary
and running for president
as an independent
because, like his VAX card says,
he never had a shot.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, yeah.
No punches.
[ Applause ]
[ Laughs ]
A runner in the Chicago Marathon
over the weekend,
stopped when she saw
a stray kitten,
but only so she could brag
to the kitten
about running a marathon.
[ Laughter ]
Organizers for the
Los Angeles Olympics yesterday
proposed adding four new sports
to the games --
lacrosse, squash, cricket
and driving to Santa Monica
for a 4:00 p.m. audition
on a Friday.
The jokes not for everyone,
but that is for our brothers
and sisters in SAG-AFTRA
who are currently on strike.
We wanted to write
a joke for them
that hopefully they can enjoy...
[ Cheers and applause ]
while we remain fingers
crossed and optimistic
they will soon get
the deal they deserve
In honor of the 20th anniversary
of the pumpkin spice latte,
Starbucks recently collaborated
with a fashion brand
to offer a limited edition
Team PSL varsity jacket.
Meanwhile, at Dunkin', they're
offering customers a shirt.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"I'm good, bro.
I'm good, bro."
The shoe brand Crocs
recently unveiled
its new limited edition
classic cowboy boot,
which will go up
for sale later this month.
The boots will cost you $120
and all of your friends.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, a library director
in Alabama confirmed yesterday
that a children's picture
book was mistakenly
added to a list
of inappropriate titles
because the author's
last name is gay.
"Well, that explains a lot,"
said recently Banned
YA author Dick Pervert.
[ Laughter ]
That was a monologue,
everybody, we're off!
We're off and running.
We got a great show
for you tonight.
He's an Emmy-winning writer
and an Emmy and Golden Globe
nominated actor.
His children's book,
"Zilot & Other
Important Rhymes" is out now.
Bob Odenkirk is back
on the show, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
He is just about to start
his second season
as a cast member
at "Saturday Night Live."
Shoemaker, you remember my
second year
at "Saturday Night Live?"
His is going to go a lot better,
which is insane and frankly,
unfair.
He's wonderful.
Marcello Hernandez
is also going to be joining us.
And she -- we're so happy
to have her here.
She was a writer here
at this very show.
She's an incredible
comedian.
Her new book,
"Unreliable Narrator:
Me, Myself and Imposter
Syndrome" is out now.
Our friend Aparna Nancherla
is back with us,
so excited to talk to her.
Also real quick,
during the strike,
I started a podcast
with my brother.
It's called "Family Trips,"
and we talked to a different
celebrity guests
about the trips
they took as kids.
We just recorded ones
with John Mulaney
and Nick Offerman this week.
They'll be out soon.
And, you know,
I've been saying every time
I hold up this picture
that I'm the cute one
and my brother
is the ugly one.
And a lot of people
don't like that joke,
but it's not a joke.
He's the ugly one.
[ Laughter ]
And I have to say that
because I want you to know
there's a podcast
where you can go for the truth.
[ Laughter ]
Well, you guys,
yesterday the Writers Guild
voted to ratify a new contract
with the studios,
bringing an end to the five
months long writers strike.
We've been back at work for a
few days, but now it's official.
And after a long summer
of picketing and chanting,
it makes sense
that they're exhausted.
And writing jokes is hard work.
They have to write hundreds,
hundreds of jokes every day
just to get the 10 or 12
we use in the monologue.
And honestly, a lot of the jokes
they write just aren't good.
[ Laughter ]
And sometimes I think they throw
in a few stinkers on purpose
just to fill the page
and meet the assignment.
But just because
we support labor movements,
that doesn't mean
we can tolerate laziness,
which means it's time
for another
"Surprise Inspection."
[ Bugle call ]
♪♪
So, here's how this works.
I'm going to read
some real jokes
that were really submitted
by my writers,
paid writers, paid better
than ever before...
[ Laughter ]
...that are unusable
for the show.
Some are dumb, some are
offensive,
some are just insane.
Most importantly, the writers
don't know we're doing this.
And because a lot of them
don't watch the show,
they'll never know.
So let's get started.
It was announced last week that
Usher will headline next year's
Super Bowl halftime show.
Okay, but who will help
everyone find their seats?
[ Light laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Matt wrote that joke.
And he was -- he was unaware
we were doing something
called "Surprise Inspection"
when he took the photo.
That's why he's smiling.
According to the personal
finance website WalletHub,
Orlando is the best foodie city
in the country.
Guys, it's expensive,
but it's so worth it.
[ Light laughter ]
Mike Scollins wrote that joke.
Mike Scollins is what's
known as a bad guy.
He's a bad guy who writes jokes
that don't make people laugh
or make them happy.
It makes them think,
Oh, my God, they are eating...
[ Laughter ]
...they're eating Shamu.
That's the kind of joke.
But, you know, let's not forget,
going back
to Goldich's jokes,
there's not ushers
at football games.
[ Laughter ]
How did they find their seats?
The [bleep] ticket number.
[ Laughter ]
Also Usher.
So there's one usher
for the whole...?
One guy running around?
Today was musician
Sting's 72nd birthday.
And while he started
his party today,
he probably won't finish
till tomorrow.
[ Light laughter ]
Now, that joke is dependent
on you
knowing that
Sting practices tantric sex.
[ Laughter ]
[ Coughs ]
Obviously, guys, you guys
don't know that.
It's literally
all Ally talks about.
[ Laughter ]
We stopped playing
sting music in the office
because if you do,
she just is like,
"Do you guys know?"
And we're like, "Alright."
[ Coughs ]
Excuse me, guys.
I cough when things
are going really well.
[ Laughter ]
Eggo has released
a new maple syrup flavored milk,
or, as it's known in Canada,
breast milk.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, it's that dude.
Authorities in Indianapolis
recently captured
an escaped pet monkey
that was spotted drinking
a beer out of a garbage can.
The monkey's name is
Slurious George.
Ian wrote that joke,
and that's the face he makes
when he writes one.
[ Laughter ]
"Do you get it?
It's based on Curious George."
"Yeah, I get it."
[ Light laughter ]
-That's -- this next one's
an Ian joke as well,
and I'm confident
you're going to think
Slurious George
is the best of his work.
[ Laughter ]
We're going to all long
for Slurious George in a moment.
Florida wildlife officials
were recently called
to a yacht club
after a bear was spotted
on a docked sailboat.
Officials gave the bear
a stern talking to
and then another one on the bow.
[ Audience groans ]
-So -- so a [bleep] bear
was on a boat,
and Ian's take on that
was not to make a joke
about the bear part,
but just that there's a bow
and a stern on a boat.
A bear.
A bear was on a boat.
He didn't think
there would be a joke in that.
I know exactly how it happened.
He was like --
We'll show him.
[ Laughter ]
Cheese delivery service
in Florida
recently set
the Guinness World Record
for world's largest
charcuterie board.
And then to celebrate,
they threw a huge party.
[ Light laughter ]
[ Light applause ]
Alright, you know what?
You got six claps.
Let's see who it was.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
You're off a roll!
Customs officials
at a Minnesota airport
recently confiscated
a box of giraffe poop
from an international traveler.
Apparently, she tried to bring
it into the duty-free shop.
[ Laughter ]
That's Brian, everybody.
And would you believe,
this is going to shock you,
his best friend
on staff is Ian?
[ Laughter ]
A truck in Ontario, Canada --
a truck in Ontario, Canada
yesterday spilled a load of
produce across the highway.
Said the driver, "Oh, no.
They're going
to garnish my celery."
[ Light laughter ]
So they went on strike.
They walked around.
They walked around
buildings like this one.
Like, "What are you
going to do without us?"
[ Laughter ]
That was Brian again.
We make him and Ian
share a desk.
[ Laughter ]
Princess Kate Middleton
participated last week
in a wheelchair rugby game.
"Ah, it wasn't for real?,"
asked Meghan.
[ Audience "oohs" ]
[ Laughter ]
If you've been paying attention,
you know that's this guy.
[ Laughter ]
The deputy mayor of Paris
last week
addressed the widespread
rise of bedbugs across the city
and said, "No one is safe."
So before asking someone
voulez-vous
coucher avec moi,
ask yourself
itchy, itchy, ya-ya, da-da.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Okay.
Credit where credit is due.
Congratulations, Matt.
You earned your smile, buddy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughs ]
I would not have guessed
that that was --
that was going to be
our heavy hitter.
In honor of Halloween,
Burger King has reintroduced
a whopper with an orange bun
and black sesame seeds
while McDonald's is celebrating
by leaving the corpses
in the ball pit.
[ Laughter ]
He was our strike captain.
He was out there
every day this summer.
And let me just say,
as our strike captain,
you did a fantastic job, buddy.
Congratulations
in everything you did.
Thank you for getting us out,
getting the writing staff of
this show out there every day.
And it is wonderful
to have them all back.
And look, they can't
all be fastballs,
but it is great to have this
writing staff back with us.
This has been
"Surprise Inspection."
[ Bugle call ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪